BASHAR RIZK: Normally,
one would use
one camera to try to
accomplish the goals that you
want to do when you're
trying to gather a sample.
You want to find
out about the place,
you want to identify
the hazards,
make sure that it's safe
to operate around it,
identify the places
you'd like to go
and pick a sample off, and
then watch yourself picking
a sample off the surface.
You can't do that
all with one camera.
It took us three.
The three cameras of OCAMS
are a low-resolution camera,
a medium-resolution camera,
and a high-resolution camera.
What we did was write
down all of the things
that we had to do at
the asteroid Bennu,
and then we conceived
of cameras that
would address those
requirements, that would
satisfy those requirements.
And it just so happened that
they have these properties that
are very similar to
sending a person along
with a pair of
binoculars on a mission,
and telling them to look
out to what's out there
and inform us what's happening.